Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P here is a caller who
doesn't like that we have advertisers and is
asking why we have advertisers. Let's listen.
Speaker 2: Hey, David, I'm just wondering why
you dedicate 10 minutes of every show to your
sponsors and trying to sell this stuff. I
just think it takes away from the overall
message and it makes your a. All right. So.
Speaker 1: All right. Now, listen. So we have
advertisers because they generate revenue for the
show. And that's why just about any successful
show has advertisers. I listen to, you know,
Cal Newport's podcast. I listen to podcasts from
Argentina. I listen to their world. They all have
advertisers. And mostly it's the same reason it's
to generate revenue for the show. Our our show
does have about 4 minutes of ads in it on average.
That's a lot less than commercial. You know,
commercial TV might have 39 minutes of content
and 21 minutes of ads, 17 minutes of ad sometimes.
So we have a lot less than that. But the reason we
have advertisers is to fund the work that we do
now. As I've said before, we estimate around 1%,
not even probably more like three quarters of 1%
of our total audience supports us with memberships
on our website around three quarters of 1%. If
we were able to grow our direct support from that
three quarters of 1% up to like 2% of our audience
supporting us directly, then we could do away with
all of the advertising on any platform, on every
platform. We're not there at this point in time.
And so the reason that there are advertisers
is to generate revenue. And I think you'll
find that that's relatively uncontroversial.
We have such a great bonus show for you today.
Speaker 5: Oh, the bonus show
where you want to make money. Yeah.
Somebody else that makes money to fund.
Speaker 2: Themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Why do we make money on the bonus show?
To generate revenue. Okay, More people are getting
away with murder in the sense that unsolved
killings have reached a record high. We're going
to talk about it. Number two, federal prisons want
inmates to pay their victims before being allowed
to make phone calls or even buy shoes in prison.
What we will discuss. And lastly, there is a
sperm donor who has fathered 550 children who has
been told it's time to stop. The reason why may
surprise you, although it may not. All of those
stories and more on today's bonus show. Sign up.
Join Pacman dot com. You can use the coupon code.
24 starts now to get a tidy little discount. I'll
see you then and we'll have a brand new show.
Unidentified: For you tomorrow.